we're going to do in this video is focus
on key misunderstandings that folks
often have and we actually got these
misunderstandings from the folks who
write the ap exams from the actual
college board
so let's say
that we are trying to take the
derivative of the expression
so let's say we're taking the derivative
of the expression
the natural log
of
sine of x
so the first key misconception or
misunderstanding that many people have
is when you're dealing with
transcendental functions like this and
transcendental functions is just a fancy
word for these functions like
trigonometric functions logarithmic
functions that don't use standard
algebraic operations but when you see
transcendental functions like this or
compositions of them many people confuse
this with the product of functions so at
first when they look at this they might
see this as being the same as the
derivative with respect to x
of
natural log of x
times sine of x
and you can see just the way that it's
written they look very similar but this
is the product of two functions
if you said natural log of x
is f of x
and sine of x is g of x this is the
product of sine and g of x sorry this is
the product of f of x and g of x and
here you would use the product rule
so to actually compute this you would
use the product
the product rule but this is a
composition here you have f of g of x
not f not f of x times g of x
so here
you have
that is our g of x it equals sine of x
and then our f of g of x is the natural
log of sine of x so this is f of
g of x
f of g of x just like that if someone
asked you just what f of x was well that
would be natural log of x but f of g of
x is natural log of our g of x which is
natural log of sine of x so that's the
key first thing always make sure whether
you're going to use especially with
these transcendental functions that hey
if this is a composition you've got to
use the chain rule not the prodigal it's
not the product now sometimes you have a
combination you have a product of
compositions and then things get a
little bit more involved but pay close
attention to make sure that you're not
dealing with a composition
now the next misconception students have
is even if they recognize okay i've got
to use the chain rule sometimes it
doesn't go fully to completion so let's
continue using this example the chain
rule here says look we have to take the
derivative of the outer function with
respect to the inner function
so if i were to say in this case f of x
is natural log of x f of g of x is this
expression here so if i want to do this
first part
f
prime
of g of x
f prime of g of x
well
the derivative of the natural log of x
is 1 over x
so the natural log derivative of natural
log of x is 1 over x but we don't want
the derivative where the input is x we
want the derivative when the input is g
of x so instead of it being 1 over x
it's going to be 1 over g of x
1 over
g of x and we know that g of x is equal
to sine of x
that's equal to sine of x
now one key misunderstanding that the
folks of the college board told us about
is many students stop right there they
just do this first part and then they
forget to multiply this second part so
here we are not done we need to take
this and multiply it times g prime of x
and let me write this down g prime of x
what would that be
well the derivative of sine of x with
respect to x well that's just going to
be cosine of x
cosine
cosine of x
so in this example right over here the
derivative
is going to be let's see if i can
squeeze it in over here it's going to be
1 over sine of x which is this part
times cosine of x so let me write it
down it is going to be 1
over
sine of x
do that in that other color 1 over
sine of x and then times cosine of x so
once again just to make sure that you
don't fall into one of these
misconceptions let me box this off so
it's a little bit it's a little bit
cleaner
so to just make sure that you don't fall
into
one of these misconceptions here
recognize the composition that this is
not the product of natural log of x and
sine of x it's natural log of sine of x
and then when you're actually applying
the chain rule derivative of the outside
with respect to the inside so the
derivative of natural log of x is 1 over
x so
that applied when the input is g of x is
1 over sine of x and then multiply that
times the derivative of the inner
function so don't forget to do this
right over here
now another misconception that students
have
is instead of doing what we just did
instead of applying the chain rule like
this
they take the derivative of the outer
function with respect to the derivative
of the inner function so for example
they would compute this f prime
f prime
of g prime of x f prime of g prime of x
which in this case f prime of x is 1
over x but if the input is g prime of x
g prime of x is cosine of x
so many students end up doing this where
they take the derivative of the outside
and they apply and the input into that
they use the derivative of the inside
function this
this
is not right be very careful that you're
not doing that you do the derivative of
the outside function with respect to the
inside function not taking its
derivative and then multiply don't
forget to multiply times the derivative
of the inside function here so hopefully
that helps a little bit if all of this
looks completely foreign to you i
encourage you to watch the whole series
of chain rule introductory videos and
worked examples we have this is just
a topping on top of that to make sure
that you don't fall into these
misconceptions of applying the product
rule when you really need to be applying
the chain rule or forgetting to do part
of the chain rule multiplying by g prime
of x or
evaluating f prime of g prime of x so
hopefully that helps